everybody and welcome to part 7 of our
matplotlib tutorial series in this video
we're going to be talking about loading
data from files so it's a really popular
request for people like how do I
actually get data from you know a CSV
file let's say is usually the most
common example but I mean there's other
files how do I get that data from a CSV
to Matt plot live now depending on the
file type and how that file is
structured and all kinds of stuff I mean
that this process can vary but for the
most part the there's two major ways to
do it one you can use the built in CSV
but two you can use numpy if you don't
have numpy same holds true for every
time is basically what I told you in the
beginning to pip install and then set of
six numpy that's it if you're on a
64-bit version of python then you might
not have the ability to just easily
download numpy so what you would want to
do i'm pulling it up at the moment is
you want to head to this website here
it's got its the unofficial binaries
website for all kinds of windows
packages and usually what I do when I
get here ctrl F numpy hit numpy BAM here
you go these are the wheels if you don't
know how to install the wheels file the
easiest thing that you can do is head on
over to Python programming net start
learning and let's say here pip just
search for pip how to download install
packages with pip click on that bad boy
why don't you know it
there's the toriel for that and we'll
move that ad for now and then so you can
come down here and learn all you know
how you can install modules either with
pip or even wheels with pips so if
you're not familiar go for it
so anyways once you're ready and you've
got numpy and all that we can begin this
tutorial so we'll let's reinstate our
PLT legend and our labels here we no
longer want to have a pipe pi at all so
just get rid of the rest of the data
basically and so first of all we'll
consider using the CSV the built in CSV
so import
CSV so let's say you had a file and that
file was called example dot text so what
we can do is we can add that file so
here we go this is where I'm building
this is where I'm writing the script so
this is the script that we're working on
right now so whatever you've got it you
can just right click new and let's make
a text document and we'll just call this
example the way that you you can use CSV
to open a txt file okay you can use
numpy to open text files that are
actually dot CSV it does not matter so
what we can do is edit with notepad or
we can just even just open it this one's
pretty simple actually I don't even need
just use a regular notepad here so let's
say you've got a file and Scott you know
separated by new line is the variable so
you might have a one two three four five
six seven eight nine and a ten and
you've got comma comma comma comma comma
comma comma comma and then you've got
random variables here let's just you can
put whatever you want you don't have to
worry about copying me just put some
data in there okay cool
got our sample file save that we'll
close that and we're pretty much all set
making the file now how do we use CSV to
read that file well first let's make
some empty lists so x equals an empty
list y equals an empty list good to go
now what we're going to say is with open
and because of my windows I can
reference this file locally if you're on
Linux you may or may not be able to do
this or if you're on Mac I'm not sure if
Mac allows that or not but you may or
may not need to give the full path to
the file on Windows you can just give
the local path and that would be example
dot txt I want to open that with the
intention to read with our and we're
opening it as CSV file then what we're
going to say is the plots will equal CSV
to reader and we're opening or reading
the CSV file and then delimiter will be
equal to a comma delimiter is you'll
here was it delimited by or something
this is what they're separated by so CSV
comma separated you know variable or
values I guess they the delimiter is a
comma in our case the delimiter is a
comma but in some cases you might have a
colon as the delimiter
who knows it could be a lot of stuff so
so that'll be plots then we're going to
say four row in plots X dot append and
right now when you read files generally
it's loaded in strings so we need to
convert them to either a float or an int
since we know they're all integers we'll
convert them the int so int row 0 and
then we'll say y dot append int row 1
okay so platz was each line right so it
was it was basically reading it line by
line
or actually plots would be like the
whole list separated line by line okay
and then we're saying for row and plots
we're going to append and each row is
separated by these comments so it's
almost like it's already built and we
might even we could have possibly gotten
away doing this another way but that's
okay
I don't really tend to use CSV but I
thought it'd be worth showing CSV since
it's built in anyway so now we've got
the the data anyways whatever we can do
PLT dot plot X comma Y because we just
populated them and then we could say the
label here is loaded from file that
should be it we can save and run that
now and there it is there's our data it
loaded that insert this interesting
graph for you to check it out from our
file that we wrote awesome let me close
this and now let me show you another way
and this is probably the more popular
way and the reason why is you can use
this to work with dates data as well
pretty easily
also numpy is just faster it's not going
to require us to do any like conversions
like like this is pretty messy so so
I'll leave this here I'll just maybe
what I'll do is I'll call this you know
part one and then I'm just going to
comment it out with triple quotes and
now we're going to do part two so part
two will be import numpy as NP again
that's just that's you know standards
basically then we'll make some space
here and then
is where we're going to write our numpy
code so what we can do with numpy is
first of all we can unpack into X&Y and
then we're going to say NP load txt so
we can use numpy to load the text file
into it and again this doesn't have to
be a dot txt it just needs to be it
could be a dot CSV it just needs to be a
file with text in it okay that's it
anyway the file that we want to load
same as before example dot txt we
already made that you do need to specify
a delimiter that is a comma and then you
have to say unpack equals true so
unpacking like with most many functions
you don't have to say like yeah unpack
equals true you just do X comma Y or
whatever two variables and unpacks but
basically what unpacking does is numpy
that load text basically returns this
list that each list has two elements in
it so what we can do is like here we
were a little unable to unpack it we
would have had to basically map the list
or basically to do that but we could
have done this all in one line but it
would have been complex but we're going
to use numpy because numpy is complex
but we don't have to worry about the
complexity we're just loading it we say
what the delimiter is and we say hey we
want to pack our unpack the variables
separated by that delimiter into X and
then Y so that's good and that's but
this will only work if you have you know
two variables like if you added a Z here
it's that you'll get an arrow say too
many values to unearth not enough values
to unpack and then if you just have X it
would say too many values to unpack but
anyway X Y that should work and then
again we basically use this exact line
so I'm just going to take this line copy
paste and that's that let me clean this
up a little bit and now let's save and
run that and again same graph just used
numpy to load it instead of CSV so
anyways that's just a really quick
tutorial on loading information from a
file another popular source of
information is online so we will
actually be covering how to load data
from the internet as well so don't worry
about that so that's it for this
tutorial if you got any questions or
comments up to this point please
do feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time